record-breaking heat will create
dangerous fire conditions today in
Southern California excessive heat
warnings are in effect from Santa
Barbara to south of San Diego triple
digit temperatures are expected across
the region
firefighters are preparing for a
potential repeat of the devastating
wildfires that tore through Northern
California earlier this month the
extreme heat could affect Game one of
the World Series that's tonight at
Dodger Stadium Jamie yuccas is there
with the impact for players and fans
Jamie good morning good morning at first
pitch tonight temperatures are supposed
to be in the mid 90s and could hit the
hundred degree mark if that happens it
will be the hottest World Series game
ever recorded the last record was in
2001 at 94 degrees and the scorching
heat has the Los Angeles City Fire
Department adding extra paramedics to
tonight's game the crowd of more than
55,000 fans expected at Dodger Stadium
tonight need to be prepared for the
dangerously high heat downtown Los
Angeles shattered a previous record
Monday hitting a hundred and two degrees
as the heat wave blanketed Southern
California cities adding to the concern
a high pressure system creating winds
that could reach 60 miles an hour in
places fire fighters are moving trucks
in place to attack flare-ups quickly
right now we're looking in some ways
kind of like a perfect storm when you
get this increased temperature you get
this wind in particular in addition that
you have such dry conditions the threat
comes more than two weeks after similar
powerful wind gust sent several Northern
California wildfires racing into
communities at terrifying speeds the
destructive fires killed more than 40
people and damaged 8400 structures this
week's hot weather is also forcing more
than 85 San Diego schools and dozens
more in Long Beach to end classes early
because of a lack of air conditioning
even people escaping to the beach for
relief were caught off guard did you
think it would be a hundred degrees in
October no they told me when being
everyone I'm here with they told me it
wouldn't be this hot and I walk out here
and I start pouring sweat like five
seconds some Dodgers players hope the
unusually late season heat wave will
help their game it's gonna be hot
when it's hot here in LA at the ball you
know it tends to fly a little further so
get some balls in here it's not just the
extreme heat that could have a big
impact on tonight's game winds are
expected to be at 25 miles per hour
coming in from right field straight at
home plate Gayle all right a lot to
think about when you go to the game
thanks a lot Jamie